dear Farah you asked a very interesting
question and quality of education is a
big issue in the Middle East and Arab
world something we we know quite a bit
about our firm owns the largest group of
schools in Saudi Arabia we have closer
assault on teachers and quality of
education is sometimes uneven so how do
you monitor that and make sure you get
the best one area we're doing is
basically we monitor the grades of the
students per classroom first cool to see
how they're doing how they're faring we
all of our students are ranked in Saudi
Arabia according to the national
standards and they are always in the top
top ten top top 20 students in the
kingdom by category but what we realize
is we need to attract quality teachers
to get the best of of the education and
one way to do it is basically to make it
interesting for professionals to enter
the education field and what we're doing
is we're giving not only attractive
packages but bonuses for excellence and
teaching so the idea is to attract
talent into the education sphere and
reward the teachers so we can keep them
and encourage excellence in education so
it's part of solution is testing and
monitoring but the other part of the
solution is providing fair pay
attractive paid to quality talent and
rewarding them so they can give their
the best to the students so I think the
monitoring could come from the
government but attractive packages and
incentive schemes could come from the
private sector and the schools that are
operated by the private secretary center
thank you very much